this episode is sponsored by endl an app
that creates personalized soundscapes to
help you focus relax and sleep the first
hundred people to click our link in the
description will get a one week free
trial
[Music]
it's probably hard to ignore the very
obvious green algae taking up most of
your screen but for the moment i want
you to try
look away from the closterium and
instead shift your focus to the area
that surrounds it at first it may not
seem that interesting just a sea of dark
blue interrupted only by tiny little
dots
but unlike the completely static
closterium those tiny dots are wiggling
around in frantic uncoordinated
directions like they're all dancing to a
million different soundtracks played at
once
there are organisms in the world of the
microcosmos that move in concerted
directed ways but this
is definitely not that
now let's focus on the closterium look
towards the tip of the algae where there
are round barium crystals wiggling
around in the same random way that those
particles we saw before were
we're gonna see
that type of motion over and over again
today because it's all over the
microcosmos found in and around many
different types of organisms and this
kind of random motion may seem
almost too trivial to discuss leading at
best to an end where i mull over the way
that randomness seems to pop up
everywhere like some kind of unifying
force that shapes our lives through
millions of tiny coincidences except
well there's no point waiting until the
end to say all that because the reason
we want to talk about this weird
wiggling motion is that this randomness
really does tie us together not
metaphorically but very very literally
and physically
this motion that you see is proof of
something fundamental not just to life
but to
existence itself
this movement is proof
of atoms
it's easy to take the existence of atoms
for granted now in the same way that
it's easy to take the existence of
microbes for granted once you know about
them and how they shape the world and
you've been told about them since you
were a child it's impossible to see the
world as existing without them but our
knowledge of both is relatively recent
even if it's built on work that spans
millennia and just as the microscope has
been essential to our understanding of
microbes it has played an important role
in understanding atoms
long before the existence of the
microscope though there was an idea in
the 5th century bce a greek philosopher
named democritus proposed that if you
kept breaking matter down further and
further you would eventually reach
something that could no longer be broken
down
that invisible thing was what he called
atomos which meant uncuttable democritus
theory was in opposition to the ideas of
aristotle and plato who believed that
the world was composed of four basic
elements earth wind air and fire
so what does democritus have to do with
the tiny little wobbles in the pigments
inside of the stenter for that we have
to flash forward to 1827. this was an
exciting time for anyone interested in
diving deep into what matter was made of
the end of the 18th century had seen
important advances in our understanding
of matter and in 1803 the scientist john
dalton drew upon these ideas to propose
that each chemical element could be
described by a particular atom
the atom became a useful tool in
developing new theories about how our
world is built and 19th century
physicists used it to describe a theory
of gases that assumed they were composed
of many many tiny particles constantly
moving around but these theories were
not proof if anything they raised more
questions about how to think about atoms
should we think about atoms as some kind
of mathematical metaphor or were they
something real and how could we find
proof of something as unseeable as an
atom
the answer it would turn out would come
thanks to a botanist named robert brown
brown was not setting out to solve the
problem of atoms it was the summer of
1827 and he was trying to clear up some
questions he had about the tiny
particles that burst out of pollen
grains like this one so he did what we
are doing right now he brought out his
microscope and he looked at some tiny
things under it while we didn't have
these pollen particles on hand we
imagined that what he saw was similar to
these oil droplets which came from the
body of a dying copepod
he said simply while examining the form
of these particles immersed in water i
observed many of them very evidently in
motion
curious about this motion brown
proceeded to do a number of different
experiments he looked at pollen from
other plants and saw the same motion he
looked at pollen from dead plants and
saw the same motion he even moved on to
inorganic materials like rocks and saw
the same motion
in water everything wiggled even if it
wasn't living and that meant the motion
wasn't something biological it was
rooted in something else
these random movements are what we now
call brownian motion and in the decades
that followed his observation physicists
began to study it in earnest so they
could understand the forces that shaped
the movement for example one scientist
noted that smaller particles exhibited
faster motion compared to larger ones
which you can see at play here in the
crystals lying within this amoeba with
the larger crystals moving more slowly
compared to the smaller ones but brownie
and motion's biggest impact would come
in 1905 when a scientist theorized that
the movement of the particles brown had
watched was the result of other smaller
particles colliding with them that
scientist you'd probably know the name
of it was albert einstein
and those smaller particles were water
molecules composed of atoms that are
packed with energy and because of that
energy water molecules are constantly
moving and colliding sometimes they
collide with each other and sometimes
they collide into other larger particles
which move erratically in response that
is brownian motion a movement shaped by
atoms and their kinetic energy
einstein's theories were built on
equations but they provided a framework
that would allow experimentalists to use
brownian motion as a way to see atoms
and their energy at work and ultimately
it was the french scientist jean parra
who put these theories to the test using
a new microscope called the
ultramicroscope to not only study
brownian motion and confirm the
equations that drove einstein's theory
but also to estimate the size of water
molecules
all of that discovery was made possible
because a botanist wanted to study some
pollen
robert brown was operating in a realm
that is familiar to us here on journey
to the microcosmos he was exploring an
invisible world
but what he studied and what he
described helped us find an even more
invisible world one that was still
invisible under his microscope and yet
responsible for everything he was seeing
not just the motions of pollen grains
but the pollen grains themselves and
everything else that was under his
microscope outside of his microscope and
even the microscope itself
what he found in those wiggles and what
you are seeing now in the same motion
more than a century later
is an invisible world that built
an entire universe
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
and thank you to endl for sponsoring
this episode endl is an app that takes
everything we know about sound combines
it with technology and creates
personalized soundscapes to help you
focus relax and sleep their app was
named the apple watch app of the year in
2020 and they have a brand new
soundscape called wind down that was
made in collaboration with james blake
the goal of wind down is to help you
transition from an active day which we
all have to a calmer state so it's also
great just before bed sound has a direct
impact on your physical and mental
well-being and by adapting in real time
to things like your location the weather
and your heart rate endl creates simple
pleasant sounds that can help to calm
your mind if you're interested in trying
out endl just be one of the first
hundred people to download it using the
link in the description and you will get
a free week of audio experiences
thank you to all the people whose names
are on the screen right now they are our
patreon patrons we love what we do that
journey to the microcosm this team is
just delighted to be able to do it and i
am so glad that other people love it too
because without them we would definitely
not be able to do it so thank you so
much to all of our patrons and if you
are interested in becoming one you can
check it out at patreon.com
journey2micro if you want to see more
from our master of microscopes james
weiss you can check out jam and germs on
instagram and if you want to see more
from us there's always a subscribe
button somewhere nearby
[Laughter]
[Music]
you